come on you all cheer come I'm here to
promote my Dikembe Mutombo Twitter
account where I'm releasing a lot of
good scoops really yeah but I feel like
if I'm Dikembe Mutombo yeah I want to
see what the rest of the Twitter is
forget about just talking about the
Sixers what else is he tweeting about
what I would like yeah doing it in his
talking form yeah like no no no no no no
neighbors do it better than everyone
like what I want to know a really
serious question I will tell you one
thing about the kambei before we go yeah
my friend went to Georgetown right and
he said that he was a freshman in
Georgetown and at the end of the night
there at this bar and Dikembe was in
this bar dikembe stands up any guy I
know you know hold on okay let me just
say yeah yeah well that's it is it
who wants to sex matumbo yep ha ha
really
that's always the story oh you say that
like you're both no I like your that was
great I love that it's made me that's
true
good it's the perfect um your
observation of the cover 3 defense how
is it evolved well look here's the thing
about the cover 3 defense right we're
talking about the game is evolved always
right we're always talking about the
constant evolution of the game and I
think what we're seeing is a return to
basics really just certain extent no
you're you're like that was actually
your strategies you just wave you know
like I am a sports team fan more than a
like I can talk probably more about like
I love the Clippers I love the Jenner
right you know sadly I know but the
Clippers at least they got some driving
I'm not being terribly injured they got
some draft but no like so I'm like a
much more of a team based guy so a lot
of the times when I was doing the league
yeah we're going into like Dallas or
Tennessee or whatever and then they're
like alright let's talk about what's
going on with the Titans right now I
don't know anything about what's going
on the Titans like well watch them
playing it so cuz it's tricky into what
I found like the technique was always to
repeat the question back and say it with
a point of view like some sort of
they're like so they're like so what do
you think that you know what do you
think what the Titans offense is here
like well look
you know Titans have what they have
obviously right and and I think what
they're gonna try to do is they're going
to try to they're gonna try to go for it
yes but they're not you know they're
never gonna push I mean because the
other day they're the Titans like I
didn't say anything
but I've just said something that makes
me feel like oh yeah right who have you
had a show you have a show the league
that resonates so much with sports fans
to where sports fans will go up to you
in public and be like man I want to talk
to you about my fantasy team and that
struggle must be so real well to me it's
like this right fantasy teams are like
your dreams no one wants to hear that
right their interests and told your
stories yeah exactly it's like it's like
showing your friends sides of your
vacation no one cares nobody like you
know but you do it's great I'm happy for
you and by the way no one wants you
about my fantasy team like but you have
people back all right who should I play
and like and the question is it's like I
finally fan seems like it's not that
easy to answer who should I play it's
like well who you playing against who do
you have mess with fantasy football but
him and other guys around the office and
friends that's all they do to me all
week oh who would you play this week
this guy or this guy and I constantly
have to answer it drives me crazy and
I'm in football yes and you're not and
which is even more crazy but you and
it's so it's in tough because at the end
of the day it's just you have no control
over these female and you you there's no
diffic so me back oh yeah I picked him
and he like scored like seven touchdowns
like there's no way that you knew like
it sometimes you just go off and you
have this amazing game we had my Walsh
in here a little bit ago and I was
talking about the the divide sometimes
between comedians and sports fans
comedians love to focus on what human
beings obsess over that is so
unimportant right and sports fans are
the kings of focusing on things like
that divided I feel like you're seeing
more than anybody well yeah because it's
like I remember I growing up you would
have like these big books like you know
you look in the book like all right well
this guy on turf he'll run for this many
yards but I got grass he's running but
you like looking at all these that's
like it makes a difference here's I'm
gonna tell you fancy football players it
doesn't make a difference damper know
it's like it's sports you never gonna
mess it's great it's awesome that's why
it's excite
to watch right it gets to me I'm
actually gonna pare down my fancy teams
because it's too stressful Elektra
sitting there my god I can't do that
it's it's a it's like yeah so I'm gonna
go down to one fantasy team and I like
this my friends have this gambling
league where you put in like 300 bucks
right and they give you like ten like
$10,000 right we can spend that any
which way you want over the season like
you can dole it out you can you can bet
$10,000 on the first game of the first
right and I like that I like but it's
like it's hard it's like because it like
I was in three leagues this year
confidence league get something else I'm
like yeah I get anxiety I get excited oh
wait they're playing Thursday and then
you forget it's Thursday because you're
also sitting your line from Monday and
it's like you there's no days off it's
too much so one thing that he does I
know he recognized you from yo gabba
gabba oh my gosh yeah kids they were
like you know Paul Scheer is coming on
and I was like man yeah exactly right I
know I was like wait I got him from one
of my kids shows they used to watch that
was a fun crazy thing like yo gabba
gabba is kind of a cooler version of
Sesame Street or Nick jr. right Nick jr.
yeah I guess like basically these two
guys were like I have these kids and I
want to blow my brains out if I watch
another Barney's or The Wiggles or
whatever the hell it is like I want to
have like cool bands on the show I wanna
have like comedians that we like on the
show and like make it at least like I
don't want to kill myself right on the
couch watching right so they made like a
fun show and I've met them at a party
and I was like oh I'd love to do your
show and they're what do you want to do
and I was like I don't want to dance you
have all these other people dancing
right like let me do comedy with
McBrayer and so we came up with
knock-knock jokes but crazy thing about
it is it's Nickelodeon and I komlin pg4
now cannot well even when you come with
PG knock-knock jokes they're like wait a
second hmm like one I dressed up as a
cop and I'm knocking the door and you
know it's a joke whatever the dumb joke
was okay well we don't want to see we
don't want to send the message that kids
should be disrespectful to police
officers if they come knocking in the
door Mike oh and there's like one Cal
customer at utters in that utter penis
so it's like yeah so it's funny to go
behind the stage penises
so yeah we would Jack and I would
basically I think we shot two days over
the course of like two years like one in
one day shot like eight of them when
another they're trying eight of them and
they just kind of like lock them into
the show he does that multiple people in
the office can tell me about was his
podcast how did this get made
yes I'm going to start listening to I'm
embarrassed that I didn't what they do
is they watch crappy movies right and
then what are you gonna break down the
plot we basically like the way I always
describe it is when you go see a crappy
movie with your friends you want to sit
down and kind of talk about what you
just saw right like what was the George
Clooney movie I watched this year that I
had I walked out on him what was the
movie Cleopatra
wait what with the George Clooney had a
comedy movie oh they are the old brother
where are the other Coen Brothers movie
right now what the hell Caesar hill hey
that was the worst movie I've ever do
what no crabs ribbit yeah there do
movies like Love Guru Gigli and Congo
well Congo cracks no cuz I had a friend
that would go to any movie that was
playing yeah go
is this Congo it would be like Mary
Poppins you're like is this Connor but I
want him to kind of settle Ace Ventura -
oh sure
one of my top 5 movies what sure it's
better than he said sure one you know
yes a total Philadelphia yeah trash day
like oh I like Dumb and Dumber more than
AIT's mnsure I would go there like I
would go there but not Ace Ventura he
gets out of a right to win somehow I
don't think in sports I will talk about
a meeting of rhinos
now this is a movie that you guys got to
watch I mean I know that you probably
look at different sports figures and how
they get into film let's talk about
rowdy rose yeah rowdy roddy piper who's
in a movie called hell comes to frog
town where he plays the last virile man
in the world he has sperm that he needs
to give to women and they need to find
these women and impregnate them in a
world filled with frogs who have mutated
from the nuclear war and hate humans now
it's the most insane movie ever he wears
a codpiece the entire movie
and and basically he's just forced to
have sex with these women it's not like
a porn in any way although that
description makes it sound exactly like
huh yeah anything I don't want to do it
I can't move for it and and like and if
they want to control him the one of the
women who brings him around like has an
earring and she like zap my god I guess
is like right but he's the only man that
has viable sperm in the world and that
was the one that we just released so you
can listen to it now about how comes to
frog does that even come that's the that
you did Conair cuz I feel like Conair
was such a great movie do things like
this we do how did this get made and
thank god this got made so like for the
Fast and Furious thank god this got me
yeah those are fast and furious nine
come on let's keep on going I just read
someone we're actually doing a live
reading of a script was the craziest
thing somebody wrote a funny spec script
called fast nine and it's the fast and
the fuehrer where the fast and furious
guys go back in time to race Hitler oh
my god the master race so amazing they
team up with Doc Brown
Doc Brown gives him a time machine
DeLorean and they go and they he put it
on he put it on IndieGoGo and he's like
I'm trying to raise a hundred million
dollars to get this made but of course
you know as a joke I saw you did
something with Space Jam - do you think
that movie will be on the thank God I
got made or how this get me know no Jam
one is like well you really watch it's
not a good really yeah I did a live read
which you can kind of watch yeah but you
think it's a good movie because we
remember it as a child right you know to
you I'm like 40 okay
35 okay so yes so it's are you 40 or you
like I'm like 40 I'm like I'm like 40 on
my plate 39 no but it's like the like
Space Jam like it exists in our heart
because it's like we were kidding right
yeah and we did a live read it was Blake
Griffin and DeAndre Jordan Blake Griffin
played Michael Jordan DeAndre played
Charles Barkley and he was hilarious his
impression Charles Barkley is insane
right and so we did this like big fun
library to that script and you realize
how that script is really really bad but
like now it's like LeBron right is good
that's what I heard LeBron is not gonna
be able to I mean I guess well I guess
isn't seeing trainwreck but everybody
said he was pretty what do you think be
honest
he's LeBron yeah exact you know it's
like that's like I have his real like
acting is just being LeBron like you
know if I can you let LeBron say funny
stuff like it's like oh that's LeBron
and he's talking about Downton Abbey
like so that's funny because it's a just
talks about not being able to get girls
what's like yeah girl abroad yeah it's
like I like LeBron just fine
but I'm like but yeah I don't know if I
need him to be like you next transition
area by the way Michael Jordan is one of
my favorite you know of course I grew up
with Michael Jordan look I don't know if
I need to see him liking and acting in
movies I don't think he needs to you
know it's like stay in your lane
everyone should stay am I gonna say do
you have the stay in your lane where
it's like you do your thing and make
billions of dollars while I'm not
jumping off the Miami Heat bench to go
pop up some fries you know like I mean
like there's a movie Space Jam about I
mean who's being made for like
McDonald's giveaway toys and like yeah
but here's the thing - who cares about
Looney Tunes anymore like one it's like
you have kids right I do I have a 9 year
on the fibro I try to always show the
Looney Tunes I've got them into like
bugs bugger they like it and the
roadrunner I've been like you gotta
watch the classic okay that's good most
kids like Rocky Patrol or what are you
again no gap again right thank God for
your children and supporting my art but
you know like yeah it's like it's weird
kids are like kind of like Muppets don't
really exist for them it's like right
yeah HBO and by the way like full
frontal I just watched the episode of
Sesame Street last week where I guess a
fire starts Big Bird's junk is out there
full package just hangin you don't
change DMBS just hanging in the wind
finally Sesame Street gets the debt than
the basic Wow Rover Suk is passing doing
it all it's so good man go go it's like
Game of Thrones with Muppets it's man so
Big Bird showing his Kahuna's
only after years you believe in him no I
know but I would like to see it maybe
all right that Khaleesi pose of just Big
Bird just naked Oscar just goes back in
the case I will say to every parent out
there right of HBO go and you are you
should because you have HBO and if you
don't come on get HBO it's the best
thing because you have a child and you
can just pop them down they have every
episode of Sesame Street I put my kid
down there three months ago and I
haven't even checked back in these guys
I got guy like about four months left
it's got every episode you know you
throw some Cheerios in a room and
there'll be fine
wait we gotta ask him you just came from
Howard Stern right yeah yeah which is
hard I mean you know that that's a
downplay compared to us oh my gosh I'm
Howard I was like let's wrap it up I got
go call we got to get over there what
was I come I always like the craziest
question yeah well I didn't because I
love to ask I think you know I didn't do
Stern proper I did the wrap-up show
afterwards and I did some prank phone
calls with those guys okay
so what I did was I prank my grandma my
grandma from New York and like Motorama
I'm from Long Island so uh so you know I
grew up all there you know it's like yep
that's my hometown my merry
european-looking okay you say thank you
yes I lose you like I was like damn is
he from England or Germany my mark I
don't know but no no damn he's from New
York but my grandma's like a very she's
become super conservative but my
grandmother should be a correspondent
for Fox News and by the way if you love
foxes no offense to you it's great but
grandma is like all she's on board right
and so I was like I've been telling her
for the last two weeks I'm like hey
grandma I'm going in New York City I'm
gonna work with Obama this fundraiser
and she's like and so no you can't you
can't and I gotta tell her again I don't
know you can't and then I called her up
today I was like I'm here I just donated
a lot of money in your name and and so
you have to be okay with it just I don't
want you to do that and then I so here's
Obama talk to Obama and the night we had
this Obama impersonator talk to my
grandma and then he was very
inappropriate with my grandma and
hilarious to see her I deal with that
Obama kept on asking her to rub the the
phone against her breast oh do that or
Gregg will not do that he's like I'm the
president I can make you do that
no I will not even do it that well not
my grandma's 90 years old and she held
in there like a champ she like showed up
to Obama and like I was like I thought
my grandma would back down to Obama no
not all Jews now my grandma I was like
you'd be like well you think you're
talking to the president you think I
tell you I'm not happy with you did a
good job as for your improv jobs the old
lady with a with the opinion and so a
few of two weeks ago where we had Matt
Walsh on here yeah we're doing improv
and I know he is so bad at improv that I
try to explain to Matt Matt I'm not
interested in you doing improv I'm
interested in Simms trying to do improv
okay I want to give you Redemption okay
I want to try one more do you mean I was
phenomenal the first day I boarded the
first time we were like we were like in
two minutes look I can't do it I can't
do it I can't do it I can't do it all
right let me set the scene for us
well maybe the issue is this right I'm
gonna give you a tip okay okay what you
just be yourself you have to be a crazy
character all right just be yourself and
act the way that you would normally act
but you can't leave okay like that's
what you have to do the users gonna be
listening and you just have to know that
you can't leave where we're at right use
yourself okay okay you're a better coach
than Mike McLintock see who's that
that's who I he Walsh playing on the
beep
get to know your guests on your show
okay holy cow that's the terracing mom
all right so we're gonna take that and
they are gonna be we're gonna be in a
cafeteria he is gonna be the lunch lady
and we are gonna be two students in line
okay okay yes all right okay okay next
man meatloaf again Chris this stinks do
you have a are you okay no sorry what do
you guys want
meatloaf no no meatloaf no meatloaf
Chris what do you want do you have rice
and beans yeah let me get it hold on one
second damn sorry can I have two scoops
please you got it you know it has been
really into the lunch lady huh oh that's
so setting my daughter she's pregnant
anyway you guys are no
what do you want that rice of guys means
please yes without our zika's oh I can't
it's not contagious
yeah it's not contagious you know I have
a very interesting fact about me you
guys never asked me about me
I brought HPV to America oh yeah the one
I am the one you contract I had some fun
in France the damper yeah yeah fun you
know so I just want you guys to know I'm
down to clown right if you guys ever
wanna you know get you know make some
sloppy joes with me you know I you know
like let's do it I could take off the
gloves we can do it all I'm told I'm not
touching you with a ten-foot pole
I always sweat sweating everywhere get
your improv skills I wasn't great there
he was like all about the rice and beans
moving along the scene for lunch every
day really he has had rice and beans for
lunch
eight months in a row yeah eight months
in a row he's one of those athletes OCD
well let's talk about that because that
was a diet that my friend had and
college dorm because that was like the
only thing that we was safe to eat in
the college dorm like rice and beans
right and that's that up right so what
is it get like so where is your right
you start big do you eat a big breakfast
or do you just go like I want to see
what your day stacks up yeah toast with
jelly on that train ride in okay guys
the wife will make about three pieces of
toast with jelly oh then I have some
vegan organic protein shakes that I will
drink right after I like it then yeah
and then I have a coffee mug oh I don't
have it here with me with three shots of
expresso restful the coffee expresso
okay I yes next presa I sip on that for
about three hours
but then lunchtime it's a nice cold
expresso these these mugs are and all
these okay feel amazing yes
and so the three shots of Express is
like this much expresso right it's yeah
okay it's not crazy that's a lot yeah
it's like your finger at all during the
day I'm drinking five to six cups over a
three-and-a-half hour span right okay so
either way but then I do Chipotle okay
yeah that's great I'm down with that a
beautiful and I do think he's got this
intense athlete thing no because he eats
the same thing I think it's the same guy
I did change it I want some grilled
vegetables with some hot sauce on top
but then I also go to Balducci's and get
a seaweed salad it was also that you
have that every day here's on this say
right I think you figured it out yeah
because we spend so much time going what
am I gonna wear today right what am I
gonna eat Oh
Woody Allen right not that he should be
the model for anybody's way of life but
I'll use it as an example here
Woody Allen has like one thing that he
eats every day for lunch so when it's
never a question it's like where we
going for lunch
turkey sandwich Zuckerberg Elon Musk
thing they were the same type of shirt
every day they have an entire closet of
one shirt you remove decision making
well it yeah it makes it makes life so
much easier it does it's like it's just
one less thing you have to think about
you can focus on your major stuff your
improv straining right and you can't
ensure pola is the with him is the worst
experience was he gets into line and if
you've ever seen people Chipotle they
are robotic right so it's scoop of rice
beans he then goes no no no no no which
causes the ecosystem of Chipotle to shut
down right thank you guys no one talks
more than rice beans right like what do
you deny a double steak yeah there's
more rights more beans and it's like
programmed in their brain to not give
more than that spoon so they look back
at the manager who then like has to
freak out and he goes no no I need more
all I'm eating is rice and beans and
they shut down I've seen people just be
like they got it now now yeah because he
said no they trained them there they're
working on that guac scoop like that
guac scoop they have to be like that's
like gold like by the way like what
merit when people say America we don't
have like enough money or whatever we
should just start selling our guacamole
to foreign countries because that seems
to be the most precious resource we have
and when they dole that out it's like
come on guys we get a little bit more
generous with this like come on it's
unbelievable I got a boat late today
I got guac and they didn't charge me for
guac Wow your port not now both of you
are eating at Chipotle I am not worried
about just one of the ricin beads okay
but you're okay with like didn't they
have like a whole thing where we were in
trash can he can eat anything in this
stomach seems to handle it okay but I
won't say that didn't the only thing
that was a conspiracy theory well it's
computers because well I just think
somebody did it properly
you think someone got in there and I
think somebody's access right you know
by the way I agree maybe I'm gonna be on
your side here that's conspiracy theory
who put a coli in the Chipotle stuff and
listen I wasn't really against it when
they did have the e.coli thing going
along the line the lines were short it
was great to get lunch because you got a
race of being a man BAM you know in our
chant the league check out of course how
did this get made what episodes of the
league check out old episodes what a
thing is done yeah what else you working
on right now right now you can watch you
can check out this show that I'm doing
with the Lonely Island called party over
here
I produced that show it's a sketch show
and it's on Saturday nights at 11:00 if
you've never seen it you could watch
this week it's kind of a best-of epic
okay I'm gonna be in the new Andy
Samberg well the island movie pop star I
have a small apartment cool so I know we
got a wrap up but I want to ask you so
working with those guys how how the
creative juice has been flowing I'm you
guys are all awesome it's you know it's
super fun working with those guys they
are it was time about this today a
little bit there they're like three
people but they share like one comedy
brain so it's like you get like the like
it's almost like Voltron like when you
were a kid at Voltron it's like they
make one super awesome yeah like one
super robot but they all are under the
same brain and it's like because they
each have a strength in a different way
so we could work on a piece or work on
something in like a Kiva has an idea and
Andy has an idea in your Mads idea they
kind of build on each other so it's been
really fun that was awesome man I
enjoyed it thanks man I really did good
you like European law yeah I enjoy it
real I get your and I hope neither of
you get a cola yeah thank you hopefully
you guys don't get a polite